hello today I am going to be talking
about the UK nerdfighter gathering it
took place on the 19th of January whose
Co ranged by myself and Maureen Johnson
and yeah if you are not a nerdfighter or
if you don't really know what a
nerdfighter is you might not find this
very interesting I don't know you might
you might do if you are a nerdfighter
you are in the correct place and I will
now talk about the gathering okay we all
decided to meet at the National Gallery
about 17 people turned up but we were
before there were 17 people but then we
counted later on and there seem to be 18
so I don't really know how many people
were there there were two nerdfighters
that came from Spain which was pretty
insane but very cool indeed so we all
decided to meet Hannah a fair share of
awkward silences cuz nobody really knew
anyone but then we all decided to head
off and go to the magic shop apparently
also it's like the oldest magic shop
ever on something I wasn't really
listening the magic shop was kind of
small but we all managed to fit in there
oh my god they have severed heads there
were loads and loads of really really
good in my parents books in the cabinets
here are some examples 202 methods of
bullying in my parents on three miracle
routines in my parents fingers of fury
in my pants so after the man is shot we
all walked over to Trafalgar Square and
the plan was that we were going to climb
on the Lions
congratulations to Rob for managing to
climb on one of the lines even though
they were quite wet
can we take gang up on lines up the list
we also try to see how many nerdfighters
we can get in a telephone box apparently
you can get seven nerdfighters in a
telephone box seven if there are any
more gatherings see if you can beat
seven then we made our way up to Hamleys
we've looked at a load of weird little
animals that moved around to start off
with that was kind of cool I guess and
then people informed me that we had
managed to find a puppy signs elephant
it's a puppy sized our burns obviously
it's just a toy elephant but still we
were we were very pleased that we
managed to find one at all so there you
go John and then we went downstairs and
look so ever lonely love a weird
wonderful stuff mainly Lego and little
there were these little wooden things
that move around down there just as we
were about to leave Hanley's everyone
was kind of congregated in front of an
escalator
just like on the ground floor by the
entrance basically what I did because I
had a camera I thought oh if I go off on
the escalator I'll get quite a good shot
so I went up on the escalator and fill
in the wall and then I saw Maureen doing
this so I did I went all the way around
and came back down and around and when I
got there Warren was texting away on a
little phone and then I heard this
me first
thank you but in other factors that
there Titus is an underground human male
entrance
Thank You unity and then only after that
happened I look to my phone I had
received a text message from Maureen
saying get ready to film an announcement
after we're done Hanley as we walked
over to the Apple store but I couldn't
film anything I got out my camera just
about to start recording oh no no you
can't do no film in here I tried to do
some recording on one of the computers
instead send it over to this one but it
didn't work
so you haven't got any footage of the
Apple store I just pretty much spent the
whole time away from the entire
gathering and just kind of checking
emails and going on YouTube and stuff
just cuz I'm a nerd and then we went out
of the Apple store and we decided to go
to Wagga Mama's Wagga MoMA's was on the
list of things to do but when we got
there it was really really busy and so
much to my despair we decided to go
somewhere else we then decided we were
gonna split up into random groups so we
handed out cards to try and split people
up but then we decided that was a really
really stupid idea and we should just
split up into groups depending on what
we wanted to eat I went to the fine
burger company and had myself a burger
we witnessed a few magic tricks back to
of the magician nerdfighters which was
pretty cool then once we have finished
eating we decided to go to Trocadero I'm
never sure if it's Trocadero or truck a
pillow or anything we had to go on the
tubes so obviously I was doing filming
on the tubes because whenever you go on
the tubes you have to do as much for me
as possible it's just just the law
having fun on the tubes and going around
on the tubes there are loads of motor
closures on the lines almost half of the
lines were closed which was nice
obviously but we made it to Trocadero in
the end I witnessed some air hockey
and I played some Mario Kart Grand Prix
I came first obviously just lots of fun
and stuff and yeah I'm shooting and
noises and loudness and it was all good
it was all good and that was pretty much
it
that was the nerdfighter gathering
you